it's great to welcome to the program
today Kalin O'Conner who's a philosopher
and mathematician as well as an
associate professor at UC Irvine and
author of the book the misinformation
age Kalin it's so great to talk to you
today yeah thanks for having me out
David so I think to start with when we
think about the way that misinformation
spreads I've read opinions or or pieces
that say we need to think about it
almost like a virus spreads others who
talk about other sort of analogies that
can be used when we just broadly start
to think about how misinformation
spreads and we can include in
misinformation actual fake news not the
definition that the current president
sometimes applies but like actual fake
news conspiracy theories fall under this
whatever types of information we want to
talk about what is the general way we
should be thinking about how these
spread through society yeah so
misinformation is such a broad topic and
I should say some misinformation is not
like other misinformation yes one useful
way people have modeled this is
literally using models from epidemiology
so model is intended to understand how
literal viruses go from person to person
to person like to people meet and then
there's some chance the virus spreads so
the analogy would be that two people
meet and then there's some chance that
an idea or misinformation spreads from
person to person part of the reason I
think this is so important to understand
is that in the middle of this crisis of
misinformation false belief fake news a
lot of people have tried to understand
ok what's what goes wrong with human
reasoning you know why why are humans so
bad at figuring out what's true about
the world and I think that a better
perspective is to ask what kind of
social environments are we in and how do
these allow this kind of misinformation
and false beliefs to spread yeah along
those lines
the average person when we hear
something that we've either not heard
before and we have to assess the truth
or falsity of it or we hear something
that contradicts a pre-existing belief
it seems that there's a number of levels
on which we're evaluating what we're
hearing and part of that is the content
itself part of it is the context and
context of course includes some kind of
assessment of the trustworthiness of
where we are hearing the information
let's start with that piece first what
do we know about how the average person
is assessing what is considered
trustworthy worthy as a source be it as
an individual person or a news network
or publication what's the process that
we go through yeah so there seem to be a
lot of things that go into people's
assessment of like okay I've heard from
something from this source do I trust
that source and some of these things are
really good things so if someone has
lied to us or misinformed us before
we're less likely to trust them this
time yes and that's smart if we know
that some news source has a really good
reputation sometimes we're more likely
to trust them and not smart but then we
also have all of these kind of
psychological little tricks and rules
for how we trust people that don't
necessarily do good things for us when
it comes to false belief so for example
we just trust people who we judge to be
more like us and that could be their my
same gender or race or they're also in
my football club and those things don't
actually guide us towards people who are
better at sharing false or better at
sharing true beliefs or helping us
develop good beliefs are there ways in
which the understanding that we have and
that institutions and corporations and
governments have in how we are making
these assessments can sort of be used
against individuals to make them more
likely to believe something that is not
true so people's understanding of these
facts about our sort of social
psychology and the way we update beliefs
yeah
so one thing that we should all
understand is that what we might call
broadly propaganda so people who have
some stake in getting us to believe
something and who are trying to get us
to believe things and this could be
industry it could be different
government bodies it could be political
parties it could be Russian agents these
influence groups often are very savvy to
the ways in which we are social learners
and our knowledge is deeply social so if
you look just to give an example at
Russian disinformation it's often
designed to you know so they'll design
some meme in such a way that they know
people are going to be sharing it from
person to person with those they trust
and they know that what's going to
happen is they're not going to be the
source of that information to others
instead everyone's gonna see it from
someone who's their friend or their
family member and so they design it in a
way to take advantage of the stock that
we tend to trust the people we know and
love and think are somehow similar to us
that's interesting so it seems that with
that there's probably also some social
status component in terms of the people
that are replicating the idea maybe I
mean I can imagine you know a simple
example would be you happen to live in a
part of the country that has a
significant anti-vaccine community as an
example and so merely for sort of social
acceptance and social status reasons you
become more likely to replicate those
ideas is that to some degree something
you've observed yeah that's absolutely
right so many people call this
conformity bias the underlying
psychological thing is that it's
uncomfortable for people to stick out
from the pack we like being like other
people and as you pointed out we in
particular like to mimic or conform with
people who we consider to be high status
who have a lot of power or a lot of
money or we think they're cool or we
just really like them and everyone else
likes them and you also see a lot of
misinformation campaigns taking
advantage of that
so for example anti-vaxxers who get
celebrities to scare everyone about
vaccines are taking advantage of this
kind of biased towards conformity and
especially the fact that we like to
conform with these high status people I
get the sense that there's some feedback
loop here between the spread of
misinformation and political Poehler is
in the United States but I'm not sure
where the circle starts so if you look
at for example what Jonathan Hite has
written about he might argue that the
political polarization is coming as a
sort of effect more than a cause in some
of these cycles but I could sort of
think about it either way I mean we
could see that for other reasons there's
more polarization and this Prime's
people to be more likely to accept
misinformation you could also think
about that about it the other way which
is that for non political reasons
misinformation is spreading more easily
technological reasons social media
whatever and that that therefore is
increasing political polarization is it
a one way thing one way or the other or
is it more of a persistent feedback loop
when it comes to polarization
I mean untangling this knot of what is
happening and why I think is really
complicated so one thing that my
co-author and I arguing the
misinformation age and we sort of use
mathematical models to do this is that
there are different things that can
cause polarization so in some ways it's
almost over determined that you can get
feedback loops based on social trust so
we don't trust people who have different
beliefs than us and so once the Leafs
start pulling apart and these polarized
community is we don't trust the evidence
coming from them they don't trust it
coming from us and suddenly you have
stable polarization conformity that I
was talking about before it can lead to
polarization too we're all conforming
and some clique in a social network
other people are conforming and because
we have these different social pressures
we won't trust or we won't uptake the
kind of information or ideas coming from
another group so that can cause
polarization just listening to different
news sources so that you have different
groups in a community just getting
different sources of information can
also cause polarization because then
they're just not sharing ideas with each
other it's such a deep complicated thing
and then as you point out there are
these things where we see for example
Russian agents promoting polarization in
the US but also taking advantage of all
that anger and emotion and hatred to
spread their
own stories in a really effective way I
mean it's yeah as you point out it's
complicated how important in all of this
is individual psychology because some of
what I've read suggests that you know if
you you could look at studies that say
well American conservatives tend to have
larger fear centers in their brains as
an example so that there's actually
something going on at at the
neurological level that might predispose
someone to be more or less likely to buy
into or question beliefs or whatever the
case may be in this broader context that
you study misinformation how relevant is
individual psychology well so there are
so many parts of individual psychology
but the particular thing you're talking
about where there's some idea that yeah
conservative and liberals have different
genes or different emotional responses I
tend to think probably isn't that
important of an explanatory factor and
things like polarization and belief so
you might call that almost like a common
cause explanation for ideology like
there are certain types of people who
are going to be prone to different types
of ideas but I think if you look at what
ideas end up glomming into conservative
and liberal often they're really random
and what we argue is that probably it
has a lot more to do with our social
psychology that holding certain beliefs
ends up being a symbol or a signal that
you're part of a group and then these
beliefs end up glomming together and
becoming part of a meaningful group
identity so there are a bunch of beliefs
are part of conservative identity or
part of a liberal identity and it's more
about group membership and maintaining
that than about just having been
innately different to begin with is what
we think what do we know about the most
effective ways to disabuse people of
false beliefs if you look at for example
the work of Daniel Kahneman he says we
might think that if you just beat people
over the head with the facts they'll
just see that their beliefs are wrong
and they'll change their mind but in
fact it sort of seems like the opposite
often happens what does seem to be
effective at getting people out of false
beliefs yes so it's sort of two
hands-on what kind of belief you're
talking about because there's so many
different kinds of beliefs so for some
of them it is effective just to give
people the facts like if you are looking
at a spider and you're like oh yeah
those spiders are harmless I'm like no
no trust me I am a spider scientist and
that is a poisonous spider it's very
easy to change your false belief in that
case that belief isn't really tied into
a lot of your ideology it's not part of
your core identity it's not part of your
signals of in-group membership and
things like that other beliefs like you
know regulating guns will save people's
lives are much more tied into people's
group membership and identity so
polarized beliefs tend to be the ones
that get to be really hard to change one
thing that seems to be effective is
using these kinds of little tricky trust
rules we all use to try to rehabilitate
groups that have false beliefs so if you
look at some groups that has high levels
of anti-vaccine so recently the Orthodox
Jewish community and Brooklyn has had
high levels of äôt boxing just going in
as a doctor who's not part of that
community who people don't know who they
don't trust and saying like look dummies
here's all the evidence isn't going to
be effective but if you have someone who
is part of that community who can say
like look we share a lot of values I'm
like you I understand where you're
coming from here's why I think you're
wrong can be much more effective so we
need ways to communicate that take
advantage of the ways humans build trust
with each other if that makes sense
yeah I mean I guess I'm imagining it
there are situations where it's hard to
find someone who's part of the group I
mean fundamentally sometimes you're
dealing in conversations that are
happening only between people who are
not part of the same group are those
inherently the most difficult situations
to make progress in yeah I mean like if
you are part of two different groups and
there isn't a lot of shared trust it can
be extremely difficult to make progress
and you know get to someone I mean one
thing that as you were saying like so
trying to have these conversations or
Sherman's mr. society share information
in this way with someone who has a bad
belief can actually go the opposite
direction it can push them away from the
good belief and push them away from you
there's been some evidence that you know
as much as you can if you can create
trust connection like a personal
connection with someone it's a more
effective way to spread information than
like sending studies and yelling at
people and being like you're you're so
down yeah I mean it's interesting you
mentioned that because I've interviewed
a lot of former extremists white
nationalist neo-nazis etc and the trend
about what eventually pulled you out and
what would have prevented you from
getting sucked in in the first place is
people who expressed empathy towards me
people who connected with me people who
participated in what would be called
sort of a community with me would be the
biggest kind of like D radicalizing
factor and seems to have been and there
definitely seems to be something
analogous between that and what you're
saying the book is the misinformation
age we've been speaking with the book's
author Kailyn O'Connor who is an
associate professor at UC Irvine
kaylynn so great to talk to you I really
appreciate your time today and I'll just
mention I have a co-author James Owen
Weatherall who's also here at UC Irvine
yes co-author I should say we never want
to forget that two people wrote the book
and we will link to it with both author
names by the way on our website at david
pakman.com slash recommendations Cailin
really appreciate your time today yeah
thanks for talking David